Marcelo bonjour bonjour comment vont les
agriculteurs face à la crise de
l'énergie est-ce que c'est aussi rude
pour eux que pour les artisans ou les
industriels c'est rue de la même manière
on est face au mur des coûts
énergétiques alors qu'ils viennent
s'ajouter aux avec pour les agriculteurs
a déjà une grosse très importante du
coup des intrans je pense aux engrais
pour l'alimentation animale au coup des
céréales augmentations des céréales
duquel se double un événement climatique
et la sécheresse de cet été et donc
c'est l'ensemble des choses qui vient se
compliquer et qui vient compliquer leur
tâches on a le même niveau de difficulté
sur les questions énergétiques donc on a
déployé un certain nombre de mesures et
dire qu'on est encore en train de
travailler sur un certain nombre de
mesures parce que le cycle agricole
n'est pas forcément ainsi que très
classique par ailleurs c'est des
productions qu'on ne peut pas arrêter
pour des tas de raisons qui sont
simplement que c'est la vie qui continue
donc quand ça pousse il faut récolter
c'est pareil pour le lait c'est pareil
pour la viande et donc on a besoin de
travailler on continue à travailler il y
aura des des déploiements qui vont se
préciser dans les jours et les semaines
qui viennent pour faire en sorte qu'on
puisse leur dire qu'est-ce qui va être
amorti qu'est-ce qu'on va prendre en
charge une sorte de spécial pour les
agriculteurs non il y a un guichet
unique qui est en train d'être déployé
mais il faut qu'on regarde si on a des
trous dans la raquette qu'on avait fait
d'ailleurs quand vous regardez sur le
covid on avait ajusté au fur et à mesure
les dispositifs l'idée c'est d'avoir des
dispositifs qui prennent bien en compte
la difficulté des agriculteurs je donne
un seul exemple par exemple dans le
secteur des endives vous avez des gens
qui avaient 80 000 € de factures
énergétiques et qui passe à 800000 et
nous voyons que tout ne peut pas être
dans les prix sinon nous aurions une
inflation qui soit qui serait galopante
et donc on a besoin d'essayer de trouver
des amortisseurs hier à votre place
votre collègue Roland Lescure a tirer
l'attention sur l'agroalimentaire par
exemple disait-il quand on fait de la
confiture faut des pots et produire un
pot en verre aujourd'hui c'est très cher
c'est aussi une filière qui vous
inquiète c'est une filière on en a parlé
on s'est vu il y a deux jours avec
Roland Lescure il a raison d'alerter sur
l'agroalimentaire parce que au surcoût
des prix de la matière première rien ne
s'ajouter le surcoût des emballages
parfois le verre parfois le carton parce
que tout ça c'est de l'énergie le vert
c'est de l'énergie les cartons c'est de
l'énergie et donc au fond l'énergie
vient se diffuser dans l'ensemble des
produits les produits de matières
premières et les produits
dont on a besoin pour transformer et
donc tout ça vient des surcoûts là aussi
c'est la question du bouclier qu'on
pourra mettre en place pour essayer de
la moindre sur vous est-ce que le
comportement des marchés correct est-ce
qu'il y a des profiteurs de guerre des
spéculateurs non je crois pas qu'il y a
des profiteurs de guerre alors après il
faudrait que tous les acteurs jouent le
jeu mais les profiteurs d'ailleurs il y
a eu un rapport d'inspection qui avait
été demandé par Bruno Le Maire Roland
les curés et Olivia Grégoire et qui
montre qu'il y a pas de profiteur
réellement de guerre après comme on est
dans un moment de tension ou parfois on
a des hausses qui sont très brutales ou
des baisses qui sont assez hop une
journée sur l'autre sur les céréales par
exemple ou d'une semaine sur l'autre on
a besoin d'avoir des opérateurs la
distribution la transformation des
producteurs évidemment mais je pense à
la distribution en particulier qui joue
mieux le jeu du passage de hausse quand
il y a besoin de passer les hausses et
puis de prendre l'ensemble des coûts
pour faire en sorte que tout le monde
trouve son équilibre il y a aujourd'hui
des entreprises
qui perdent de l'argent si jamais le
produisent et donc ça peut pas être
durable de ce point de vue là est-ce que
vous craignez un effondrement de la
consommation on achète plus de gâteau on
achète plus de viande parce que c'est
trop cher alors structurellement non en
quantité il y a pas un affrontement il y
a une re répartition qui est très
différente c'est à dire qu'on a une
dégradation de la consommation des
produits sous label de ces produits de
qualité des produits bio vers des
produits première et donc là pour le
coup il y a une dégradation peut-être de
la qualité des produits qui sont
consommés mais surtout
pour les pour les producteurs français
pour l'instant industrie agroalimentaire
qui avait fait le choix c'était un bon
choix et c'est ça reste un bon choix
d'avoir des produits soucis ni sous la
belle de qualité là il y a des
mouvements qui sont puissants alors
est-ce que ça durera longtemps ou est-ce
que c'est juste le passage de cette de
ce moment inflationniste qui qui sera
marqué et après on reviendra influ
normal c'est ça sur lequel il faut être
vigilant moi j'ai une grande vigilance
d'ailleurs on va on va mener des travaux
très rapidement là dessus sur les les
producteurs bio et les produits bio
parce que là on a une des baisses de 10
15 20 25% de la consommation et cela
pour le coup ça destructure le marché
est-ce qu'au contraire la France a des
cartes à jouer par exemple sur les
céréales puisqu'il y a des difficultés à
cause de la crise en Ukraine est-ce que
on exporte mieux plus cher bah on
exporte pas nature plus cher puisque le
marché des céréales est un marché
mondial
ça permet de dire quand même qu'on a on
voit bien que dans ce type de crise on a
besoin d'être en capacité d'exporter
parfois vous savez on a des débats en
France sur le refus de encore
internationaux il faut être vigilant
pour que nous intéresse soit défendus en
particulier nos intérêts agricoles mais
par ailleurs dans un monde qui est très
déréglé les dérèglements climatiques
voulaient évoquer les dérèglements
économiques les dérèglements
géopolitiques on peut pas être dans une
situation où on est à la merci d'une
situation guerrière d'un dirigeant tel
ou tel qui déciderait de bloquer sa
frontière et d'empêcher les les échanges
et donc on a une carte à jouer sur les
céréales sur le lait sur la viande sur
un certain nombre de produits il me
semble que là on a des cartes à jouer il
faut qu'on garde notre capacité
exploitatrice et pour garder notre
capacité exportatrice il faut garder
notre compétitivité à propos de
l'intérêt agricole le président de la
République est en voyage aux États-Unis
il défend beaucoup l'industrie contre
les lois anti-inflation prises aux
États-Unis l'agriculture n'a pas d'enjeu
dans ce voyage si si il y a des enjeux
autour de ce qu'on appelle la taxe Trump
vous savez qui avait été une taxe de
rétorsion notamment sur les produits
viticoles qui a lourdement pesé il y a
un moratoire aujourd'hui qui était
décidé par le président Biden l'idée
c'est de sortir de ça c'était un
contentieux qui télé par le pour le coup
à l'aéronautique mais il mesure de
rétention avait porté sur les produits
agricoles particulier vitivity vinicole
on voit le bout donc ça on va on verra
bien comment ce sont déroulés les
échanges mais on voit bien il y a
quelques tentations protectionnistes aux
États-Unis donc il faut qu'on essaie de
regarder dans quelle mesure on peut
lever ses doutes ça pesait lourdement
sur la filière on sait très bien que les
États-Unis c'est c'est un des grands
marchés en débouchés des produits
viticoles la Chine aussi est un marché
elle est en crise en ce moment
économique et politique elle est en
crise économique et politique d'un choix
qui a été celui du ce qu'on appelait le
zéro covid
qui n'a pas été le choix des pays
européens et pas en particulier choix de
la France et donc on voit bien que c'est
il y a des risques profonds de récession
parce que c'est des des régions entières
qu'on ferment des activités économiques
qui ferment et il y avait des risques de
Nas de déstabilisation à l'intérieur et
puis des risques de déstabilisation
économique donc c'est un sujet
qui doit attirer notre attention on voit
bien que d'ailleurs quand on regarde ce
qui se passe en Ukraine évidemment avec
ce que fait Vladimir Poutine les
tensions qu'on a en Chine les tentations
protectionnistes on est quand même sur
des éléments qui doivent nous interroger
sur
les tentations de repli sur soi qu'on a
au niveau mondial et puis le fait qu'au
niveau européen il faut pas être naïf il
faut se protéger il faut aussi se
protéger mais en même temps on voit bien
ce à quoi mener le protectionnisme il y
a des années ou des dizaines d'années
nationalistes mais à la guerre et oui et
donc il faut faire attention quand même
à ces mouvements là qui qui sont dans un
certain nombre de pays vous l'évoquiez
il y a le réchauffement climatique au
dessus de tout ça vous la France a subi
une sécheresse cet été vous avez fait
une sorte de tour de France un
déplacement encore récent sur le sujet
Quels sont les dégâts
ancienne élégant de nature différente
alors sur les céréales pas
principalement puisque au fond la
plupart d'entre elles sont récoltés au
mois de juin en revanche sur le maïs des
dégâts très importants et puis des
dégâts surtout sur les prairies on a
déjà une plus d'une dizaine de
départements qui ont été classés au
titre des calamités agricoles donc c'est
des dégâts d'alimentation pour le béta
puisque
le fourrage n'est plus là le maïs tout
ça c'est des éléments qui manquent avec
des prix qui sont élevés donc ça fait
une double peine pour un certain nombre
d'éleveurs donc ça et puis un certain
nombre de cultures et c'est là qu'on
voit en quoi l'accès à l'eau est un
accès déterminant je pense au maraîchage
je pense à l'arboriculture je pense
parfois à la vigne qui ont souffert très
très puissamment de ce de cet épisode de
chez stress dont je dis quand même au
passage qu'il n'est pas complètement
terminé on a un anniversaire on a un
hiver qui est pour l'instant est sec et
qui fait que alors on va laisser passer
l'hiver on est qu'en entrée d'hiver mais
quand même avec ce qu'on annonce y
compris sur le mois de décembre la
pluviométrie va rester très déficitaire
sur l'année 2022 et il va falloir
absolument alors maîtrise pas les cieux
mais il va falloir absolument qu'on
essaie de reconstituer cette réserves
sinon nous aurions une année 2023 qui
pourrait être à risque est-ce que les
bassines de Sainte-Soline seront
creusées toutes mais c'est la volonté
qu'elle a notre c'est des décisions qui
ont été prises localement il y a eu des
décisions et des recours de justice qui
ont donné droit au à ceux qui portaient
les projets je rappelle toujours que sur
certaines solides on était sur un projet
ouais aujourd'hui on pourrait 21
millions de mètres cubes au bout on va
en prélever 12 millions et sur les 21
millions tous étaient prélevés en été et
la moitié de ce qui reste à dire les 12
millions ça va être prélevé l'hiver donc
on a réduit de deux tiers le prélèvement
en été donc c'est un projet vertueux
dans lequel on essaie de sécuriser la
ressource et en même temps les
agriculteurs s'engagent sur la réduction
de consommation et donc on a besoin
d'eau enfin ce n'est pas une question du
maïs globalement une question de toutes
les cultures et dans un mode de
dérèglement climatique on a besoin dans
les périodes où il y a trop d'eau de
pouvoir la collecter la bassine c'est
l'avenir quoi ben sous cette forme là
les réserves les retenues d'eau les
retenues de substitution parfois c'est
des ouvrages qui sont plus importants
je dis souvent ça quand vous regardez
les tirages le niveau de la scène cet
été à Paris il a très peu baissé
pourquoi il a très peu baissé parce
qu'en amont il y a des grands lacs qui
avaient été fait d'ailleurs avec
l'accord des agriculteurs qui libère
sert plutôt à lutter contre les
inondations de la région parisienne on
va d'ailleurs continuer cette politique
là les agriculteurs acceptent compris
d'être inondés l'hiver et donc c'est
grands là qu'ils ont permis ils
permettent l'hiver d'éviter les
inondations ils permettent l'été
d'assurer l'irrigation l'alimentation en
eau potable et le soutien du niveau de
la scène donc avec un intérêt écologique
donc on a besoin d'ouvrage pour réguler
ses flots d'eau qui ne sont on a une
forme d'arythmie météorologique qui fait
qu'on a des périodes sans eau du tout et
puis des périodes avec beaucoup d'eau et
donc c'est ça qu'il faut réguler la
justice a pris des peines à donner des
peines symboliques contre les
écologistes qui ont commis des violences
lors de du rassemblement anti-sensoline
ça a créé de la colère parmi les
agriculteurs cette indulgence c'est
relativement
de commenter les décisions de justice en
tout cas nous avions mis les moyens
Gérald Darmanin avait mis les moyens
humains les forces humaines pour éviter
le les débordements quand bien même il y
en a eu et pour montrer que à la force
de rester à la loi parce que si c'est
dans la rue qu'on décide de la viabilité
au nom d'un projet c'est la force et la
violence qui dicte la viabilité d'un
projet à la à ce moment-là on n'est plus
en démocratie on est deux sous une autre
forme de régime ce que j'appellerais un
régime autoritaire pour pas dire pire et
donc il faut que force reste à la loi
certains appellent ça de la
désobéissance civile non c'est pas de la
désobéissance civile c'est
fondamentalement le refus d'appliquer
des règles de droit et quand vous êtes
dans cette logique là vous prenez des
grands risques pour la démocratie la
communauté juive la communauté musulmane
sont inquiète de voir l'abattage rituel
réguler pendant ce quinquennat voir
modifier voire interdit est-ce que vous
pouvez les rassurer oui oui il y a
aucune difficulté à les rassurer ça
n'est pas la volonté du gouvernement ça
n'est pas ma volonté il y a un équilibre
qui a été trouvé ça procède d'ailleurs
d'une réglementation européenne qui
autorise ces dérogations il faut
respecter aussi chacun dans son culte il
y a des efforts qui ont été faits y
compris la modernisation des abattoirs
pour procéder à ses abattages rituels
dans de bonnes conditions sanitaires et
donne bonne condition en général pour
les animaux et donc il faut il annule
volonté chez nous d'aller réouvrir ce
débat qui a découvert 20 fois ou tenter
d'être ouvert 20 fois il me semble que
là on a un équilibre qu'il faut tenir
hier on a appris que la baguette entrée
au patrimoine mondial immatériel de
l'humanité est-ce que ça peut aider
aussi les producteurs de céréales pas de
baguettes sans farine oui d'abord ça
permet de mettre en valeur l'ensemble
d'une filière qui commence par les
céréaliers les gens qui produisent les
céréales qui sont nécessaires à la
production de baguette et puis au bout
de la chaîne les boulangers le
savoir-faire français c'est un élément
très symbolique y compris parfois dans
l'iconographie extérieure au pays que la
baguette on a souvent été représenté de
cette façon là donc c'est un élément du
patrimoine qui est important et puis ça
permet de montrer la valeur qu'on donne
aux choses et en particulier les
céréales les prix des céréales se
tiennent en ce moment pour les raisons
que j'ai évoquées en début de notre
notre entretien mais évidemment ça
permet de montrer l'intérêt de conforter
cette filière un mot du MoDem est-ce que
le modem est déjà en train de penser
l'après Macron qu'est-ce que vous allez
faire en 2027 d'abord on est six mois
après l'élection du Président de la
République le MoDem a toujours pensé
c'est pas la question de la pré Macron
la prévision de la République il faut
jamais se mettre dans ses postures là
parce que c'est
sa personnalité trop sa personnalise et
par ailleurs ça donne le sentiment de
brûler les étapes et moi je vous savez
qu'au modèle on est plutôt sur des
sujets de temps long on essaie de
réfléchir plutôt les choses comme ça ce
qui n'est pas facile dans le monde dans
lequel on vit la question en revanche
qui est devant nous et qui faut qui sans
cesse revisiter pour l'espace central
que nous représentons que nous avons
incarné avec François Bayrou et que nous
continuons d'incarner François bayraud
c'est celui de comment on trouve une
force d'équilibre au centre et
l'échiquier politique et comment la
construire et c'est ça le travail que
nous avons à faire et on sait qui peut
être candidat en 2027 il l'a dit
d'ailleurs je trouvais que c'était assez
injuste le procès qu'il a été fait il a
dit qu'il s'interdisait rien mais vous
demanderez à la plupart des responsables
politiques du niveau national qui
s'intéresse rien parce qu'on ne sait
jamais ce qui arrive dans la vie
politique Marcelo merci et bonne journée
merci